you considered yourself a nerd growing
up you thought of yourself as a nerd i
mean i i was yeah down to the uh like
literally
tape on the glasses and the bow ties and
uh it was it was i mean i used to
literally pray i remember being in my
bedroom and praying to god please please
make the girls like me please make the
girls like me
and uh
luckily i grew into myself and things
started to change we we have a
photograph of you as there you are
see i think that's a fine i mean i think
you look fine it's just the glasses are
are large the glasses are quite large
those are those are large women's
glasses that you're wearing right there
gloria gloria vanderbilt yeah exactly
but but do you think did you think you
were a nerd or did you know that you
weren't a nerd and that you would uh
grow up i knew that i had the potential
to not be a nerd right but i would if
somebody called me a nerd i'd be like
yeah you're right i'm gonna nerd
but uh but uh you know it for me it was
all art school art school
uh i went to a school the performing
arts and it changed everything because
they gave me the confidence that i
needed then i could then i could blossom
and now i'm here today
i yeah this is the pinnacle this is it
it doesn't get better than this uh
you are uh you know you're you're a
manly man i'm going to call you a manly
man
but you but you've admitted to having a
bit of a soft side oh yeah well
especially now i'm uh you know uh you
may or may not know i'm going through a
divorce now so i never know what my
emotions
are going to do at any given point in
time so
i literally could
meet somebody and they'd be like hey how
you doing i'd be like i'm good
and you know when people are like really
how are you and i'd be like
that's a little good
it does look good
and i give that uh that brad that brad
pitt brad pitt cry yeah
is that the bradford
[Laughter]
it is you know so it's like you're in a
you feel like you're in a bit of a
fragile state absolutely and you can
just be anything like you're watching tv
commercials
commercials make you cry totally totally
totally ugh it's embarrassing there's uh
there's two commercials one is i don't
know if it's for guinness where it's
it shows all these guys and and uh
if i tear up i'm gonna punch you in your
face
all these guys that's not fair
you're making me all these guys are in a
wheelchair i forget is it maybe it's
going to get guinness let's just say
guinness because you get free guinness
all right
it's forgetting
the best beer of them all ever in the
world all these guys i keep doing this
all these guys are in wheelchairs
and they're talking about teamwork and
whatnot and and how it's not just for
one person everybody has to be a team
and then at the end of the commercial
you realize everybody gets up from the
wheelchair except one dude
and you realize that all these people
were playing basketball
with the dude in the wheelchair and they
were all getting in the wheelchair to
make him feel included right that's
but that is touching isn't it i
shouldn't feel bad about that i i'm the
same way and i will i mean that's a
really touching commercial i'll see ones
where it's just like you know a new 99
cent breakfast at denny's
that's really an expense
it's so reasonable
i don't even have a good reason to be